[Music]
Leena thank you so much for being here
as I said everybody is talking about
this show and you be pretty exciting
right now thank you yeah it's it's it's
been an amazing journey as they say
didn't need quotes but I'm glad you put
them on SEC's people are saying this is
Sex in the City for the next generation
and it does feel I think they're
probably shows you've tried to make that
claim before but it does feel like
you've you've captured something about
this young generation and it is you
really know this world well thank you I
kind of think about it as a show for
girls who came to New York having
watched Sex in the City and wanting the
life that they saw depicted on that show
but then they got them they were like no
Manolos they had to like wear mismatched
sneakers on the subway and like their
boyfriend was not Kristen off and
everything was just had gone to hell in
a handbasket and that sort of the world
that I was trying to capture one of the
things I think is very endearing
interesting about the show is that you
seem fearless about as we just saw in
that scene you you will make yourself
you know very vulnerable in this show
there's some very graphic sex scenes and
you are you know really willing to put
yourself out there and maybe not always
in the most flattering situation is that
right I would say that's an accurate
representation what I'm doing I mean the
sex scene thing is funny because I do a
lot of sex scenes in the show and I'm
usually nude for them because unlike so
many films we see where women are having
sex and like a kind of a perky negligee
a lot of times people get naked to have
sex I think I never have actually I'm
always in a tuxedo to have sex with you
I don't wanna have sex with you I'm
sorry
I understand you want to but you respect
my wedding ring yeah so basically the
sex scenes I will be sitting there lying
there kind of being slammed by a naked
body thing I want out of this bed I want
out of the scene I want out of this life
who did this to me and then I realized
I'm my own boss I've written it I'm
directing it I'm the person holding
myself in sexual slavery right you did
this to yourself yeah yeah and so there
was one time on set where I was doing a
sexy I say it's easier to do awkward sex
scenes I think than it is to look like
you're enjoying yourself and I was doing
a sex scene and Judd Apatow who's the
executive producer of a wonderful man
was on set and he's never pushing me in
the nudity direction if anything he
pulls me back and goes we don't want
this to look like a fetish why don't you
put your shirt on but so I a fetish of
yours of yours butt out so anyway I was
doing the sex scene and I said you know
what I'm done I think we got we need and
judge said no Lina you need to do
another take and I was like at this
point chafed exhausted wanted no more of
it and he said um we need you to do
another one because you look like you're
being murdered yeah yeah so you look
like you're enjoying yourself